oh wow you guys aren't gonna believe how
delicious this is hi I'm Susan Feniger
today I'm gonna be making one of my
favorite dishes boyo Ciudad with pickled
tomatoes I think you should try this
dish because honestly even without the
chicken is one of my favorite dishes
I've ever made and that's for the last
37 years oh my gosh I'm old this is a
dish that I learned many many years ago
on one of my first trips to India and so
many of these flavors come from India
yet they're very similar to flavors we
use in the Latin kitchen from the time I
was a little girl I used to lick the
fudge paddles with my mom in the kitchen
and I started working in restaurants but
I didn't really think about it seriously
until I was in college and the army cook
I worked for was the one that said what
are you doing studying business used to
be a chef when I first started which is
way long ago I was one of the very few
women in French kitchens that I worked
in but you know what I was a tomboy and
so I was in there with all the guys and
I had a great time but for sure you had
to prove yourself so I think we probably
had to work harder as a woman than you
did as a man in those kitchens to prove
yourself but you know I think that made
me in some ways a better chef one of the
things I love about the restaurant
business I think for many LGBTQ youth
particularly who may have been rejected
from their family the restaurant
business can often create a second
family and support system that's
wonderful you know I've been out for so
many years as a lesbian in the
restaurant business and I think there's
so many people who are LGBTQ in the
restaurant business and always has been
and so for me this place was always very
safe and warm for me to be out and open
but for me I was always comfortable
being who I was in the kitchen
environment one of the things I want to
make sure you remember is when you're
adding in the cilantro stems and the
leaves don't cook it for very long
literally throw it in wilt it and turn
it off because what happens is as you
continue to cook it the leaves lose a
lot of their color and even some of
their freshness and flavor one of the
most important things while you're
cooking is taste all along the way I
like to taste every step to make sure
I've sees in each element properly so
you'll see that I'm adding part of the
heavy cream into the sauce initially
because sometimes my chilies will be
spicier than other times sometimes the
cilantro will have more flavor than
other times so if I added too much heavy
cream the sauce is too mellowed out you
could always add more but what you can't
do is take it out and you'd have to sort
of start from scratch again so add a
little bit and then add more later once
you taste it the flavors that we're
looking for with this sauce is I want to
have a hit of cumin a strong hint of
cilantro and then I want that vinegar
and the brown sugar balanced so you've
got the earthiness from the cilantro and
the cumin and the mushrooms and then
you've got the spice from the chilies
and you have the sweetness and acidity
from the vinegar brown sugar mixture all
those flavors together that to me gives
you this great strong flavor profile I'd
have to say the thing I probably love
the most about being in the restaurant
business is the creative aspect of it as
well as being in a position to be able
to give back to charities that are so
dear to me you know I have been on the
board of the Los Angeles LGBT Center for
the last 12 and a half years this is one
of the most rewarding things I have ever
done in my life and I'm honored to be a
part of it oh yes